طبعا بحديثنا عن الفرح اعتقد ان اعظم صوره
نرى فيها الفرح جميعا ان كل الاوجه وكل
الالوان وكل الاجناس يقفون في هذه المنطقه
ليذهبوا الى مكان واحد لاداء النسك الاعظم
نتحدث اليوم بالتاكيد عن اكثر من مليون
وثمانمائه الف حاج اليوم يصلون الى
المشاعر المقدسه ليؤدوا نسك الحج بكل يسر
وسهوله وطمانينه بحديثنا عن العيد هم
يعيشون عيدا مختلفا تماما ويعيشون ايضا
مشاعره كبيره في وجودهم بالمشاعر المقدسه
ووصول بعضهم الان الى الحرم المكي الشريف
لاداء طوافي الافاضه ثم ليبداوا بعدها
الذهاب لزياره اقاربهم او عائلاتهم او حتى
التحلل بعد اداء طواف الافاضه بحديثنا
اليوم بالتاكيد عن مشاعر الفرح والسرور
اليوم هو العيد الذي يجمع الجميع تحتها
مظله واحده هي مظله الاخوه والسلام والحب
والتعايش مع هذه الحياه نعم اذا كل هذه
الاعداد التي تصل اليوم الى المشاعر
المقدسه والتي لاقت اهتماما كبيرا جدا من
الجميع هنا في مكه المكرمه نتحدث على يوم
الترويه ويوم عرفه واليوم يوم العيد ويوم
التضحيه نتحدث اليوم بالتاكيد عن ان هذه
المشاعر الكبيره وكل هذه المناطق التي تضج
بالحجاج تملاها الفرح والسعاده والسرور
كان وصلنا الى هنا استغرق تقريبا ثلاث
ساعات جميع شوارع مكه المكرمه تبتهج فرحا
بحجاج بيت الله الحرام وايضا تضج
بازدحامات شديده الاحتفالهم بهذا اليوم
العظيم طبعا هناك عاده دائما ما يكون اهل
مكه في ميعادها تماما في ايام الاعياد وهي
توزيع المشروبات الحاره والبارده كذلك
العصائر والمشروبات ايضا الاخرى والمياه
كذلك على الحجاج في كل مناطق مكه المكرمه
وبالمشاعر المقدسه على وجه الخصوص نتحدث
اليوم اذا على ان هذه الاعداد تصل اليوم
بشكل متفاوت وباوقات معينه الى الحرم
المكي الشريف او الى المشاعر المقدسه كذلك
دون اي ازدحامات تذكر هناك انسيابيه كبيره
جدا في وصولهم الى هذه المناطق هناك ايضا
اليوم نستكمل الخطه التشغيليه الثانيه بعد
نجاح الاولى في يوم الترويه ويوم عرفه
نبدا اليوم ونستكمل مع ايضا رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين وايضا اكثر من اربعين جهه حكوميه
تشارك اليوم في تنظيم كل هذه الجموع
الغفيره طلايا الحجاج اليوم
تخرج بكل هذا البياض للعالم اجمع وبرساله
واحده وبقلب واحد اننا على هذا المنهاج
وعلى هذه الطبيعه ولا هذه الحقيقه نعيش
هذه الحياه بكل تاكيدهم سيخرجون الان ايضا
بشكل متفاوت تقريبا الى العصر سينتهي
الجميع من اداء الافاضه ويعودون الى ميناء
مجددا قواكم الله يا اسامه وكل عام وانتم
بخير يعطيكم الف عافيه كما هو الامر موصول
والشكر موصول لكل من قام على خدمه حجاج
بيت الله شكرا
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات